what is the secret to not blinking
uh why do I not blink I'm I I watch your
performance specifically uh I watched
the episodes again yesterday and I'm
like it's amazing how little you blink
when it's a close-up on you go that's
interesting because Michael Caine
famously said in his master class you
know whatever happens don't blink you
know
have you seen that I've heard all about
it and it's true though when you're
watching an actor not blink you're being
pulled in and uh it's just anyway but
you you do it very well I'm just curious
what's the secret
uh I don't I wasn't even aware that I
was doing that I think it's I think it's
just like the intensity of the character
and the kind of the mindset that he's in
um it just sort of
you do these things that sometimes you
know you can intellectualize about the
character and the formation of the
character but but sometimes what
actually happens to your your facial
expression or your or the way that
you're you know I wasn't conscious it
was probably the it was probably the
it was more kind of the thought process
than than actually thinking right I'm
gonna not I'm not gonna blink you know I
I you know it's it's really it was about
I suppose he he is an intense character
and I think there's a sort of
um
a natural Authority that he has and and
I I created this backstory for King
noloy which was was that he was this it
was like a kind of a shop steward in the
form of life and and he has a family and
and and yet and and he would have fought
for workers rights on the outside you
know before he was incarcerated but he
would have been seen as a troublemaker
for that so when he when he was
incarcerated he uh he then kind of
almost sheds any desire to to look out
for other people apart from himself just
do his time and get out try and get out
and just survive the sentence the
torture the the the uh you know the the
desensitization and I think it's that
desensitization that made me perhaps
have that sort of slightly kind of lost
but kind of
hardened and toughened shell maybe maybe
that's where that intensity comes from